blade Smith welcome to the forge because
this is forged and fire and we like to
throw curve balls at people in the first
round of competition today you'll be
using
these mining
tools so choose your mining tools wisely
because all of these tools are made from
different types of Steel your 3-hour
Forge time
starts now we have the option of using
1085 carbon but I'm going to play it
safe I'm not going to do a forge weld
it's still more beneficial for me to go
with an unknown source of Steel than to
spend my time possibly doing a forge
weld that might not have a good hardened
spine come on baby get hot interesting
he's putting the whole pickaxe head into
the forge my plan is to use the back
Spike as a handle that saves me the
trouble of having to go to the band saw
and cut it off I've got a built-in
handle why not use it I I'd like to hope
that he's going to try stretching one
end of that pickax out see how much he
can get out of it I'm not going to try
and for weld I trust this steel Better
Than I Do by time
management my plan is whack the metal
really hard my concerns is that I'm only
using one metal but I'm doing what I'm
feel comfortable with after I've got the
blade profile the way I want it I start
drilling holes for my dowels to go
through the bits are
screaming oh my gosh so two things are
going on either the bit is very dull or
my Blade's already hard storm grabbing a
new drill bit I've probably got 10 or 15
minutes into drilling one
hole there he goes all
right I'm loving this power
hammer this thing does in seconds what
it would take me hours and lots of
aspirin to do I feel
great I don't have a power hammer at
home I've never even seen one I prefer
to hammer shape it I remember my
great-grandfather pouring water onto his
homemade Anvil and hitting it that's
what symbolized the blacksmith to
me I'm going to try and Stand Out by
doing something with a little bit more
of my style which is more of an artist
approach yeah he's just marking that
blade up I like it I'm trying to create
something a little bit more artistic I
think straight lines compliment curves
he's putting some part of himself in
there look something that's a little bit
more imperfect but
handmade storm is just quenched
everything seems good but there's a
slight
warp I don't want to turn in a warped
blade that's just one reason for me to
go
home if I do a three prong pinch in the
vice I might be able to take this warp
out I'm grabbing a torch and I'm trying
to get this thing back
straight
ha it's straight and I just feel so
[Music]
relieved I'm getting ready to quench the
blade I'm nervous I've got butterflies
the adrenaline's
pumping I've got tunnel vision I can't
see what's going on around
me everything looks straight I don't see
any
cracks thank you
Lord
ne's in the quench I really enjoy the
fact of a knife being shaped about 80
85% of what its end result is going to
be but my biggest concern is that they
don't like my style like it's a little
too primitive or it's a little too
unfinish for them 5 4 3 2 1 blad Smith
shut down your machines drop your tools
your forging time is
over blad Smith welcome to the strength
test you each get three coconuts one
shot each remember this is not about
what happens to the Coconuts it's about
what happens to your knife Neil you're
up first you ready yes
sir Neil it chopped cleanly it felt
comfortable got a little bit of a curve
to the blade but you had that before
your Edge held up fine nice job Neil
thank you
being from Hawaii if I had a knife that
didn't cut a coconut I would never hear
the end of it ready Dan yes sir let's do
it Dan I was concerned because you have
a much thinner edge here but apparently
dialed heat treat and just right you did
take some of our advice by reducing some
of this thickness here I wish it had
been a bit more because you have that
bend in the blade it's not in line with
my hand but uh it held up tight nice job
Dan thank
you storm what are you
thinking I'm nervous very nervous well
we're going to do it anyway yes
[Music]
sir
heart's beating out of my
chest storm we've got some definite Edge
damage some chipping and
rolling um worried that all of that over
forging continually heating
straightening might have pulled some of
the strength out of your blade your
handle stayed tight though I appreciate
the fact that you have you know that
little bit of belly on there that helps
me hold on to it didn't hold up 100% but
he still did a very nice job thank you
conly to test the sharpness of your
blade I will take your blade and slash
across these ratchet straps meel you up
first you ready yes sir let's do this
okay well Neil it's ni you made a little
adjustment so we request
your little finger weld there did not
get in the way it's very smooth but it
feels good in the hand overall your
blade will
cut right on good job Dan you're up next
you ready yes sir let's do
this all right Dan talk about your blade
your handle I like the way it feels it's
got a good grip nice finger swell right
there so I can hold on to your blade it
slice nicely it feels good in the hand
but when you look at it you still have a
slight warp to that but overall your
blade will cut thank you all right storm
it's your turn you ready more than ever
let's do
this
good okay storm let's talk about your
blade it is one of the smoothest handles
we've ever had from a second round good
job on that thank you here's some of the
issues though it's a small handle when
you're working with blades that are
bigger than your hand it becomes blade
heavy you start chopping and hitting
around it it wants to leave the hand cuz
it's so smooth your blade here almost
has serration now it grabbed onto the
ratchet straps and cut all the way
through overall your blade W cut waited
a long time to hear that thank you
blad Smiths the judges have made their
final
decision it's time for one of you to
leave the
forge storm your blade did not make the
cut storm your energy and enthusiasm in
the Forge was amazing to watch I mean
you've obviously got a passion for this
and you produced a fine piece but the
forging and the heat treat on your blade
just couldn't stand up to the strength
test with those coconuts so that's why
we have to send you home today
completely
understood storm please surrender your
blade would have been nice to go further
but it's the way the cards fell and that
unfortunately led to me going home
failure isn't fatal and success isn't
final it's the courage that counts so
I'll keep living by that motto and
moving
forward
[Music]